Avengers: Infinity War left a lot of dangling
questions.
Among the most important: where was the Hulk?
The big green guy all but abandoned Bruce
Banner in the battle against Thanos.
Was his absence just build-up for an Endgame
triumph?
It's a good bet that he'll be back in the
big Infinity Saga finale, which makes us ask
one big question: could a vengeful Hulk actually
put Thanos to bed permanently?
Here's all the ways we think that might happen.
One of the most defining elements of the Hulk
is that the mean green brute is strong.
Really, really strong.
There are so many layers of pure, unadulterated
muscle that it has always been a primary trait
over the decades, whether it be on the printed
page, television set, or cinematic universe.
After all, the Hulk's the best there is at
what he does, and what he does is, well…
“Hulk Smash!"
At this point, everyone knows that if you
hit Hulk hard, you're only going to be hit
back harder.
Of course, this natural ability to "muscle
up" makes Hulk a prime choice to use in any
kind of one-on-one showdown.
If Hulk starts smashing, you can bet there's
a fair chance that Thanos' demise might occur
under those two giant green fists.
But, of course, the question that naturally
arises from that statement is whether he'll
start smashing in the first place.
The biggest mystery about the Hulk when it
comes to Infinity War is just where he was
during the whole ordeal.
When push came to shove, with the universe
at stake, Hulk was a non-starter.
He had a peek around, took a few lumps from
Thanos, and called it quits quicker than anyone
else in the film.
Of course, that doesn't mean Hulk was really
done.
Anyone who watches that opening scene can
pretty quickly see that the Jade Giant wasn't
quite in character.
He looks dazed, confused, and half-committed.
It turns out, according to the Russos themselves,
Hulk wasn't so much scared by the confrontation
as genuinely angry about it.
Director Joe Russo stated plainly on the commentary
track:
"People have speculated on whether there was
some fear on the Hulk's part about having
to face Thanos again but I think ultimately,
what it is, is that he's tired of playing
hero to Bruce Banner."
And after two years spent in control on Sakaar,
can you blame him?
Regardless, if Hulk's going to stop Thanos,
he's going to need to get over his hurt feelings
and take the reins once again.
Of course, Hulk's absence actually plays nicely
into his chances of dealing the final blow
to the Mad Titan.
As of the end of Infinity War, Thanos sees
the Hulk as nothing more than a passing annoyance.
His attention in Endgame will probably be
more focused on characters like Thor, who
already stabbed him in the chest, and Captain
Marvel, who's been confirmed to be the most
powerful superhero in the MCU.
This could play into the Avengers' hands nicely,
as everyone else knows that Hulk really is
one of their best chances at beating the living
daylights out of Thanos.
Perhaps, rather than a straight-up brawl,
it'll be the element of surprise that could
help the Hulk rise to the occasion and be
the one to take down Thanos.
Once Hulk gets over his hurt feelings, he
might feel a twinge of embarrassment at having
left everyone to fend for themselves during
what was clearly the largest crisis that the
Avengers have ever faced.
If he really did sit out because he was being
a baby about the whole losing control issue,
once he has a chance to process things with
Banner, he might even feel a little remorse
and regret at how everything went down.
Plus, the fact that he was made to look like
a fool could give Hulk a healthy dose of inspiration,
not to mention a vendetta against the guy
who made him look like an idiot while he was
taking a time-out.
Before we move on to more specific ways that
Hulk could take down Thanos, let's talk about
one more "big picture" element that could
factor in here.
Hulk is strong, sure.
But, honestly, he's not the only member on
the team that can go toe-to-toe with Thanos
and have a fighting chance.
Even Iron Man got him to bleed a little, right?
"All that for a drop of blood."
But one thing the Hulk has that the others
don't is the exponential scaling of his rage.
Hulk literally thrives in adversity.
If he feels outmatched, he gets angry and
his strength scales along with it.
He's virtually untouched by fear, too.
If the Green Goliath can get angry early enough
in a fight with Thanos, there's a good chance
the Mad Titan side of that equation is going
to have a rough go of it.
While the thought of a furious Hulk giving
Thanos a run for his money is as good as gold,
there's one weapon that Hulk could use that
would make the entire affair that much better.
For a while now it's been heavily rumored
that Tony Stark's part in the endgame of Endgame
involves him reassembling the Avengers and
building his own Infinity Gauntlet.
Another rumor indicated that it might be none
other than the Hulk who wields the second
gauntlet in battle against Thanos.
The theory even comes with the added speculation
that Hulk may end up losing an arm in the
process.
Whether he loses an arm or not, though, the
simple fact that Hulk could end up wielding
the Infinity Stones could give him all the
power he needs to kill Thanos.
While it's fun to think up "Hulk smash" scenarios
that could lead to Thanos' demise, the truth
is that after Infinity War, there seems to
be something of a Hulk special being cooked
up at Marvel Studios.
A while back, actor Mark Ruffalo explained
that the Hulk had a story arc taking place
over the course of three separate movies:
Thor: Ragnarok, Avengers: Infinity War, and
Avengers: Endgame.
This led to a bunch of rumors that point to
the idea that Hulk's story may actually end
in reconciliation between himself and Bruce
Banner.
A burying of the hatchet between the two could
finally pave the way for the arrival of Professor
Hulk, a version of the character who has the
brains of Banner and the brawn of the Hulk.
A Hulk that's as smart as he is strong could
be just hero to finally take down Thanos.
Speaking of Professor Hulk, even if we're
fairly certain about his appearance in Endgame,
Marvel Studios has been tight-lipped about
how the synthesized character could actually
appear.
And, of course, whenever Marvel is reticent
about something, the fans are ready to step
up to the plate.
One particularly interesting theory about
the transformation actually involves The Ancient
One, Tilda Swinton's character in Doctor Strange.
The theory suggests that Banner will head
back in time along with everyone else via
the Quantum Realm.
Once there, he'll cross paths with the Ancient
One, who will help teach him how to control
his anger and bring about the healing that
the two so desperately need.
There's some evidence to support it, too:
Mark Ruffalo did refer to working with Swinton
in an unnamed project back in 2017.
The Ancient One has also been reported to
be among the action figures being made for
Endgame, so it's certainly possible.
While there's no doubt that Hulk is a top
contender to take Thanos down, he's certainly
not the only option on the table.
In fact, there are quite a few other people
who are actively standing in line in front
of him.
The guilt-laden Tony Stark has a laundry list
of reasons to be the guy who takes the kill
shot.
Nebula's list might be even longer at this
point, and besides, she was critical in toppling
Thanos in the Infinity Gauntlet comics.
Thor is just plain angry about everything
at this point and wants some revenge somewhere.
But even if someone else actually kills Thanos,
Hulk could be an instrumental piece of that
scenario simply by being a distraction.
How often do the Avengers get the important
stuff done while Hulk is busy doing the dirty
work?
In the Battle of New York, Cap led the team
and Iron Man saved everyone's butts by dealing
with the nuke.
But Hulk was the point man, taking down alien
hordes right and left in a spectacle that
drew a ton of attention.
"And Hulk.
Smash!"
He's done the same in numerous other battles.
If his ultimate role is to play the distractor,
he'd know the part backward and forward by
now.
Another way that Hulk could ultimately kill
Thanos might be by simply stepping aside and
letting Bruce Banner do the work for him.
While he may have been dodging his responsibilities
in Infinity War, getting the Hulk to come
out and play isn't necessarily the key to
everything going well.
In fact, puny Bruce Banner may have a much
more important part to play than we think.
One heavily rumored element that could be
critical in Endgame is the aforementioned
time travel via the Quantum Realm.
The problem is, who's going to be able help
everyone move back and forth through time?
Scott Lang has the experience, but he's lacking
the scientific know-how.
Shuri might be able to do it, but based on
what we've seen in the Endgame trailer, she's
fallen victim to Thanos' snap.
At the end of the day, having someone like
Bruce Banner on hand to guide the team through
the Quantum Realm could be just the brainy
ticket the team needs to take Thanos down.
We've spent a good amount of time breaking
down Hulk's furious rage and how it could
be a factor, but one popular theory is that
we'll get to see World Breaker Hulk.
Who is World Breaker Hulk?
In essence, it's the strongest manifestation
of Hulk that we've ever gotten to see in the
comic books, and certainly one that could
give Thanos a run for his money, with or without
his fancy pants Infinity Gauntlet.
One popular fan theory pointed out that the
timing would be pretty fitting.
Thor has pretty much finished his evolution
into a nearly all-powerful being, while Hulk
is lagging behind and due for a story arc
finale.
And, as we know, Avengers: Endgame represents
the end of the arc that Mark Ruffalo has discussed
in interviews in the past.
Perhaps the stars are aligning for World Breaker
Hulk to take on Thanos and reverse the results
of their first meeting.
Whether it's due to his strength, his fury,
a second Infinity Gauntlet, or anything else,
Hulk needs to have one more critical factor
going in his favor if he's going to topple
the Mad Titan: he needs to have an interest.
Hulk's care-free attitude toward Thanos has
crippled his ability to have any positive
impact on the storyline.
On the contrary, his actions seem to have
simply allowed the universe to go to hell
in a handbasket.
No matter how many Captain Marvels or Ant-Men
show up to try and save the day in Endgame,
Hulk is going to need to get his act together
in the big Avengers finale.
He has to get over any petty squabbles with
Banner and team up to focus on the true danger
at hand.
Both characters have serious upsides, especially
if they're working together.
Oh, and Banner's probably going to need to
get angry.
"I'm always angry."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.